let's let's jump into the first story
check this out it's from Sky News a
couple days ago police woman bitten on
the arm while explaining Cova denied
teen lockdown rules Greater Manchester
police released photos of the injury
suffered by the 21 year old PC after she
was attacked in Rockdale all right I'm
gonna give you guys who are watching a
warning we're gonna show you can see the
bite almost on screen I show it just so
you know she got bit yeah that's a bite
dude that's a you can also see how the
teeth are crooked because you can see
like how the lines are yeah this was
like a ravenous bite yeah so we were
actually thinking like will will she now
get infected with kovat from a bite
considering as a respiratory illness I
think so you think so well I mean well
did the person have Kove it I mean we
don't even know X we don't know cuz it
was just they were just explaining the
course a guy man did it he bit a female
officer on the arm heck dude she was
explaining the rules now here's the
crazy thing
toxic masculinity I'm telling you wait
wait hold on why would he bite her I
don't know who I was or punch and then
point because what was he doing that he
became that aggressive unless unless
zombification is phase 2 I mean no you
know you got a thing getting by the way
was it just going grabbing her arm and
biting or was it like a tussle I didn't
so I guess my punch to other cops so
they were probably like wrestling and he
just bit yeah I mean there's a couple
other stories real quick and then we'll
read what happened turns out we have
this one from crime online they say
quarantine man runs naked from his house
bites woman to death during coronavirus
lockdown hates it so so eighty year old
woman or something right how often do
you hear stories about people biting
other people to death I mean I I don't
know but you know there's a lot of
earthquakes all the time in California
right and now everyone's talking about
it
so is it is it that people bite normally
and the facto a human thing to bite it I
think I think that's the that's it right
there cuz so I did a segment Krakatoa
erupted you know yeah yeah his famous
1883 it was it was hurt actually 3,000
miles away
mm-hmm and a bunch of people died from
the shock wave and so now there's news
coming out that Krakatoa erupted and
people are all going like oh man the end
of the world because it's huge volcanoes
erupting
interrupted apparently two years ago all
right yeah nobody cared and I was like
Oh bright but now that we have lost
crazy stuff going on people are bored
but man those pictures are really cool
if you haven't checked them out there's
like like wait man nine out of the top
we're not done sweet check this out
is this story from April 4th to this
bugs rotavirus patient bites nurses face
after she tried to stop him escaping
from quarantine dude she got bit on the
eye yeah that's uh that's uh that's
crazy man it's a really terrible spot to
get bit but she's looks it looks like
her eye is okay she got bit yeah now
check this out UK cops warn suspects are
using coronavirus as a weapon now is
that because they're consciously trying
to bite and spit on people or because
they're zombies
let's go because it's more fun you know
but you know what's funny about all
these stories is that of course they're
not zombies
of course not but this is literally how
a zombie apocalypse would happen if it
was yeah like like we were talking about
this before like Shaun of the Dead you'd
see news reports of people getting sick
of someone biting somebody and you'd
think nothing of it
but let's let's let's read this first
story and figure out why exactly she got
bit they say Greater Manchester Police
released photos of the injury suffered
by the 21 year old PC after she she was
called to reports of a man causing
disturbance in Rockdale officers tried
to explain to the man that he should not
be going to other people's homes
following the government guidelines
tackle the kovat pandemic the four said
while trying to engage with the man two
officers were punched and the 21 year
old was was then bitten she she attended
hospital following the incident on
Thursday evening before being discharged
to recover at home days earlier she had
been delivering Easter eggs to children
while out on patrol
okay this story's got so much wrong with
it Wow oh my
Christopher l-29 of no fixed abode has
been charged with two counts of assault
by beating of an emergency worker and
one kind of criminal debt damage is that
basically saying he's a homeless guy yes
so let's actually soloed for a second so
police the cops were trying to tell a
homeless guy that he had to go home and
then they try they try shoot like
jamming in this thing which like you she
was giving up
Easter eggs - children right I don't
care that's total propaganda trying to
make us sympathize I look you already
got my sympathy dude bit you Yeah right
crazy homeless guy but this is this is
nuts man did you see that there was a
viral tweet where the police in some
part of the UK were like think having a
picnic in the middle of nowhere and
you'll be safe
think again oh yeah we'll pop out of the
shadows and get you right I saw that
yeah what's up what's going on dude what
do they think homeless people are
supposed to do where what home yeah go
home where okay where do I go officer
they said they're telling him he can't
be going between people's houses or
something what are you what is that
supposed to mean what does it say hey
what I don't know the more we read into
this the less I had trust going to other
people's homes what is he supposed to do
he is due to appear at the Manchester
Magistrates Court on Saturday
GMP chief constable ian hopkins
described the attack on an officer
during the court virus pandemic as just
the lowest of the low
writing on twitter words fail me when it
comes to some people's behavior you know
what all I can think is harumph I say
how dare you sir yep we were trying to
corral you to do what we wanted you to
do and you said no he said pictures of
the officers bite injury were quite
graphic but he hoped they helped people
understand the vicious nature of this
attack I guess because we're in the
pandemic everything is related to the
pandemic everything so if someone gets a
bit they're gonna be like the pandemic
oh oh you know pazham bees that they're
real that it's happening but it's like I
actually wonder if we should have looked
you know maybe we should ends before
looking up the stats for like how often
a cop is bit yeah yeah look up like a
bite crime biker might bite right I
don't know what else you have you ever
said that before
my friend has ever heard it has anyone
bite crime Lydia pull up a bite crime
statistics fight crime and while you do
I mean this one if there's any stories
that so there first of all the first
story we ever saw about this I think was
in India where a guy went to a
checkpoint and they tried to stop him
then he's like went nuts rip his clothes
off and started biting people put the
RIP in the clothes off thing I don't get
that I don't know
I don't get that there's something about
what like being crazy and being naked
that go hand in hand it's the adrenaline
pumpin you get all amped up and just I
need to feel the air on my snow yeah I
remember the Coney remember the kony2012
guy no what was that remember you do
remember Oakley 2012 was now this video
came out wasn't it in 2012 and that came
out yeah it was like the stupidest
documentary I'd ever seen because it
starts with this thing about like social
media and it's like we can all come
together and share ideas and it shows
like the globe and like people with
phones and then all sin it turns into
something about this very specific
warlord in Uganda that I don't care
about okay and they were like now that
we have your attention and we did this
very thought-provoking piece on social
media let's all team up to go after Kony
a guy who was in all likelihood dead
they don't tell you that part but so
what happened was this thing goes viral
it was the fastest viral video in
history at the time the dude who made it
like a week later was found in the
middle of a street naked jerking it and
like like pounding on the ground while
doing it what something goes hand in
hand with being crazy and being naked I
don't know maybe maybe there's a
scientist who can break down for us is
there any any indication that he was
biting anyone no just curious he was
just he was you know pulling off while
slamming the ground that's what you're
doing with the thing with the same
motion or was it like two hands molten
one hand was slamming one hand was
pulling so look I mentioned that story
in India we have this other one
quarantine man runs naked from his house
bites woman to death like whoa yeah been
an 80 year old woman and so what it is
yeah better jugulars yeah yeah and he
just like saw her standing there this is
in India too
yeah I don't get this at all man I mean
the only two naked people were in India
the guy in the UK wasn't naked maybe
there's something about being naked and
being in India hmm well there was a lady
who walked into an airport completely
naked and tried to buy a ticket
somewhere in India no it was here in the
US I think huh yeah she got a big
trouble where did she hide her or did
she hold her credit card I don't I don't
want to know in the crack don't want to
know you can purchase a card
I do not know that's crazy the men
allegedly bit the woman in the neck
though one was taken to the hospital but
died three days later
so then we have the nurse I'm not gonna
read through all the all these stories
cuz you know where we are being a bit
silly but this is serious no it
definitely it is it but at the same time
it's like what of what are our sharpest
objects if you don't have nails like
your teeth so it it's kind of not really
that surprising that it's like people's
last resort to bite someone because
they're if they're trying to wrestle you
down and they got your arms and your
head is free and what are you gonna do
you're gonna bite the closest thing and
there's probably that woman's arm you
know I read this and it's probably not
true
but I was reading this it was probably
on reddit so you know of course it's
true right if it's unread it sure it was
something about humans were evolving
venomous bites hmm because we have like
the dirtiest mouths of any creature on
the planet and a human bite is like
guaranteed to become infected so the
very least humans have infectious bites
so it says there are 250,000 human bites
in the u.s. like total you actually
found statistics on bite prime so I was
chasing
okay so didn't come up under bite crime
the one thing that came up when I was
googling bite crime was McGruff the
Crime Dog so take a bite out of crime so
25% of bites get infected because human
mouths are disgusting yeah every time
every time I hear bite crime I just
imagined some dentists kind of like I'm
kind of like a Batman who Batman fights
crime is the dentist bites crime I don't
know scruff McGruff takes about it it's
a little rough yeah okay okay okay so
look you know what man if in three
months you know we're we've got like our
sleeves ripped off and like shotguns and
like leather boots and we're running
through the city and zombies are chasing
after us we'll look back on this and be
like we were so dumb
we saw it going but in all seriousness
it's just people biting people but the
actual seriousness of this is that UK
cops are warning people are actually
using coronaviruses weapons so whether
or not they're mindless zombies they're
bad people who how do they how are they
explaining that their their coffin on
people or what like so let's see this
spitting coughing and attacking yeah the
Essex Police Assistant Chief Constable
Paul Wells issued a warning Wednesday
after two saturday incidents in leon sea
and on gar where cops were coughed on or
bitten as they made arrest more bites
bites it gives more bites
how often do cops get bit can you look
that up or or is that the same same
report no this is from look this is from
April 2nd and the one who got bit was
from April 11th Oh which means it is
different stories okay people are biting
maybe more than usual what's going on I
don't know the facts here but but you
weren't you are right like a cops
arresting somebody right yeah so they
grabbed them the guy bites their arm
right at probably makes sense yeah I
mean I don't feel like that's that
surprising someone is rage wait wait see
in red I'd imagine that if this was that
common cops would wear things on their
arms to avoid getting bitten like if it
was that common they'd all do this like
oh I don't get bad I'm gonna arrest
somebody better put you know better wear
long sleeves mm-hmm but they don't which
says to me I've got arms not even a
sweater huh well sure yeah that's not
really gonna stop teeth nobody's not
gonna pierce the skin you'd be surprised
I mean look it'll hurt you'll get
bruised but I'm wondering because look
at this picture this cop he's he's
wearing short sleeves which says to me
they don't expect to get bitten hmm so
this is it some crazy if people are
using Crona virus as a weapon and they
are biting at the very least we can say
the bites are up and the police are
warning about it right the fact that
they're warning about it is saying
something it's like so we're getting a
little bit of like an official thing
from cops going hey they're starting to
bite us yeah maybe totally not kovat
related right probably not but pandemic
related you know I mean okay like if
there was any pandemic or people were
sick because I've seen videos where the
people are like I get you know they'll
say they have it and start spitting at
you so they know that you're worried
about infection there was actually and I
think those on red is unethical lifepro
tips you ever see that subreddit mm-hmm
it's basically there's like lifepro tips
okay where it's like you know clean your
dishes as you cook and you
do the dishes anymore or some like that
what's that that's a really good tip by
the way yep please don't do that do it
trust me it makes cooking so much better
anyway uh that's the contract
unethical life pro-tips was like if you
get pulled over just start coughing in
safe because you have kovat and they'll
leave you alone they actually won't
you're probably it detained even longer
yeah but that's the jail now they're
they're getting people for just going
out of their house so if you go out of
your house and you have you claim you
have COBIT you're a terrorist now yeah
dude I mean they're basically going
there right I mean they've already said
that's terrorist threats or terrorist
attacks when the woman coughed on the
judge some fruits and veggies those
terror right so if you start coughing
like that that's the terrorist threat
towards a cop well that's kind of like a
biological weapon right if you know that
you have it yes that's that's like the
point they sounds like a biological
agent but things things are getting
crazy man so where we live there's
already been I think three arrests we've
we've talked about there was a we might
I mention this other day was a couple
people walking the cop said hey you
can't be out and then they yelled
something like you know a few to the cop
arrested him but we went to the store
the other day and there was a sign up
that said public ordinance you have to
wear a mask in public you can't go out
and like all of these retail shops that
were supposedly like we I got an email
from all these job saying like we're
doing curbside delivery you know come on
down just tell us what you need we'll go
get it for you now they're all closed
even the hardware store was closed so it
seems like things have definitely gotten
crazier or quieter whichever one you
want to you know look at yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you